(Overlapping voices sing)
(Singing ends)
(Applause)
Hi, my name is Holly, and I’m an artist.
That was my voice,
but I didn’t sing that clip.
I trained an AI on my own voice,
and now she can sing anything
in multiple languages.
Her name is Holly+,
and you just heard her perform
“El Cant de la Sibilla,”
which is a traditional song
arranged by Maria Arnal in Catalan.
Not a language that I speak
and not a vocal tradition
that I've trained in.
Those melismatic runs
are really difficult to hit.
To show you Holly+'s full range,
I'll also play an example in German.
This is "Mack the Knife" by Brecht.
(Singing in German)
(Music ends)
Of course Holly+ can -- thank you.
(Applause)
Of course, Holly+ can also
perform my own music,
so here's an excerpt
from my own song, "Frontier."
(Singing "Frontier" in overlapping voices)
(Singing ends)
Holly+ uses a process
called timbre transfer,
where the timbre,
or sound quality of one sound,
may be mapped onto
the performance of another.
Timbre transfer is done by creating
a machine-learning model of a sound.
In this case, it's my voice.
So I recorded a wide variety of phrases
in my entire vocal range.
To be clear, this version of Holly+
is reading notes from a score.
So I'll also play you an example
of her singing in Spanish,
“Bésame Mucho” by Velázquez.
(Music: "Bésame Mucho")
(Music ends)
Thank you.
(Applause)
I can't speak Spanish, by the way, so.
Teaching an AI the sonic
properties of one sound
in order to generate an entirely new sound
is what I like to call "spawning."
Spawning is what allows Holly+
to create a wide range of vocals
that I didn't sing
from a set of recorded phrases
that I did sing.
I like to think of spawning
as a kind of 21st-century corollary
to the musical tradition of sampling,
which had a really big impact on both
music and intellectual property.
But I think spawning is far more exciting
and potentially really weird.
(Laughter)
So, for example, with sampling,
usually you copy and remix a recording
by someone else to create something new.
But with spawning,
you can perform as someone else
based on trained information about them.
And as an artist, this is making me
rethink my own past work
as not only my archive
but potentially also I myself
could become reanimated with AI.
This also opens up the question
of how we deal with
a collective human archive
if we can reanimate old media.
It opens up really big ethical
and intellectual property questions
that require entirely new
conceptual and legal frameworks.
One way that I like to think
about intellectual property
I call identity play.
So rather than limiting
the use of my voice,
I'm creating instruments
to allow as many people as possible
to create music with me, and even as me.
That's why I've made versions
of Holly+ freely available
for anyone to use online.
If I can allow people to play with my IP,
my digital identity,
my intellectual property,
what might they come up with?
Could someone else go on tour as me,
with my permission?
Could I be in a thousand different
bands in multiple languages?
And what would that even sound like?
To be clear, musicians have been taught
to be really protective over our IP,
and that's for really good reason.
But I'm trying to think of ways to make
this new capability mutually beneficial.
So to allow people to use my voice
but still to maintain the ability
to approve certain derivative works.
So I invite you to consider,
if given the opportunity,
who would you like to perform through?
And can you imagine someone
else performing you?
With that in mind,
I'd like to invite the incredible
musician Pher to the stage.
(Applause)
So today, Pher will be performing
his own song, "Murky."
And with one microphone you'll hear
Pher's beautiful, natural voice.
(Pher vocalizing)
(Audience cheers)
And with this microphone,
you'll hear a live version of Holly+
developed with Voctro Labs.
(Pher vocalizing in Holly+ voice)
(Laughter and applause)
Take it away Pher.
(Pher singing "Murky")
It gets so murky
Loving what you know
But I, I keep on swimming,
I'm swimming
Further up the road
See, the problem is,
I don't know what to say
When you come around
Acting this way
Oh oh
And, yes, the truth is
I show you every day
Cause you love to stay
(Applause)
Living in all the pain
And it gets so murky
Loving what you know
But I'll keep on swimming
Further up the road
And I've been calling out
Calling out your name
Deep down in my sleep
And I even memorized your face
So ain't no leaving' me
And I just handle my biz
And keep the train moving on
And you know what it is
Is just you that
I'm choosing
Cause it gets so murky
Loving what you know
And I'll
I'll keep on swimming
Further up the road
And it gets so murky
Loving what you know
And I’ll,
I'll keep on swimming
Further up the road
Swimming
I'm swimming
Further up the road
And I'll keep on swimming
Swimming
Further up the road
(Vocalizing)
(Cheers and applause)
Holly Herndon: Thank you.
Thank you.